little chips ahoy out of the box on the
table so we can show
sally's wrong right now okay
show me an actual cookie look at the
cookies on the package
that is perfectly symmetrical a bite
with every single chocolate chip they're
deep they're rich
the cookie's golden brown you do not
want to do this to yourself i do
you don't want to be trying to do it to
myself you don't want to pull out a
chips ahoy
i'm dying to do this to myself pull one
out but look
this is the thing it's look at those
[ __ ] things they're beautiful
that's the cgi cookie joe that's not
someone's real picture joe
all right show me a real one ha ha ha ha
show me a real one
look at that show me a real look at this
okay there's a real one right there
broken in half
but bro if you think that's the same you
are you you need you that is insane
as a matter of fact the one underneath
it that's not broken i don't see a chip
i don't even see a chip now let's
let's you want to know what looks
identical identical
to the package knock knock who's there
it's the oreo
look at that that's an oreo and that's
what it looks like on the package and
that's what it looks like in the box
it's a cookie it's punched it has the
ridges it has a thing
that is exactly you're getting what you
pay for every time first of all
i will say first of all the crest
imprinted on the cookie
has always depressed me it looks like
something that would hang over a
courthouse or a church or something
it makes me very sad when i look at it
that is there's nothing fun about it
at all there's nothing fun about this
cookie this cookie looks like it came
from the great depression
it did it didn't change since 1930
that's because it didn't nato it didn't
change by the way we're talking about
the originals only
but oreos they there's a lot going on
with oreos right now well tell me what's
going on
because i've really presented the case
for the chips ahoy it's a crisp cookie
it's got enough give that it doesn't
need to be a softie
it's got a nice balance you're talking
about it in his best form chip chips
versus cookie flavor
and you can barrel a sleeve of them like
no other i mean it's
you you do your barrel sleeve of chips
ahoy better than you can barrel a sleeve
of oreos watch me okay let me touch me
i could do one arguing that's how easy
let me talk a little bit
they made chips ahoy that have oreo
cream inside the chips ahoy i wonder why
because chips ask yourself that question
because chips ahoy said you can come
into my house if you want
you're still in my house i'm not coming
into yours you think i'm going to let
your cookie
surround me oh is that is that how you
want to spin it your
spinster that's not a spin you're a spit
you spun
it they're like we need what oreo has
that's the secret ingredient everyone
loves we need to have that
to even be able to compete with them to
walk in the door to put on the same
shoes as oreo
oreo is also by the way oreo is in
everything let me tell you oreo is
they've taken oreos and put a
blizzards and shakes and ice creams
and oreo cookie pie wow talk to you
about that
oreo crust taste buds they coming to the
mic
talking about the food they hate talking
about the food they like two fools gonna
fight but only one food can be right
taste buds man yeah they're coming to
the mic i'm talking taste buds
taste buds if you don't want your purse
they'll take your pay stubs
taste buds taste buds better put on your
boots make sure they're laced up
what does that have to do with it